do you find
computer vision machine learning
from the perspective of tooling as an
interesting tool for
analyzing for processing all the data
from the neuroscience world from the
neurobiology biology because ever all
the different data sets that you can
have about the mind the eye
the everything that's neck and above
and also the central nervous system and
all right absolutely i mean
i think that computer science and
engineering and chemistry
bioengineering is that's what's creating
the
acceleration and progress in
neuroscience right now i think it's
actually one place
where science i'm very reassured science
has
invited in psychologists computational
biologists at least at stanford mit and
and other places too of course it's
clear that
it's a everyone's invited kind of party
right now
the the major issue in the field of
neuroscience at least
through my view is that there's no
conceptual leadership no one is saying
we need to work on and solve this
problem or that problem
it's very fragmented right now now the
good news is people are communicating so
computer scientists and people work on
ai machine vision are talking to
biologists and vice versa
but it's very dispersed is there a lot
of different data sets like
in your work that you've just come
across is there a huge
number of disparate data sets around
neuroscience and so on or
well there's a lot of cell sequencing
stuff so the broad over it you know
on in boston and then on this coast the
chen zuckerberg
initiative um what you know um
they did you know three billion dollars
to sequence every cell type
in humans and in animals and try and i
think their goal is to
cure every disease by some date i don't
know in the
in the future um huge data sets
of gene expression and protein
expression that's valuable
i think no one really knows how to think
about neural circuits
and what what is a neural circuit um is
it one structure
is it two structures communicating i
think
this is where i actually think that the
robotics is going to
tell us how the brain works because it
it's tempting to think that the brain
has all these cell types
and circuits in order to solve specific
problems but
it might be that the fundamental
algorithm is to create cells and
circuits that can solve
variable problems we know in the retina
just a very simple example is that
we've always heard about like cones are
for color vision and high acuity and
rods are for night vision and
and non-color vision but at the dusk
dawn
transition certain cell types switch to
do completely different have a
completely different function for
viewing starry night versus
what they do during the daytime so
neurons multiplex
and i think building machines that can
multiplex
and can evolve themselves is going to
help us really understand what the brain
is doing
we need to tease out the fundamental
algorithms we know they're like motion
detection and
spatial vision and things like that i
think machines are going to be much
faster at that than
our understanding of biology and how the
brain does that
basically i'll be out of a job and
people like you will have a job no well
no though
i think the main idea is that uh there
won't be a job
that's machine learning or a computer
vision it's just
it's a it's a tool that neuroscientists
will
use more and more and more and uh
biologists would use i mean this whole
idea that it will just be a
a tool that allows you to start
expanding the kind of things you can
study
well the next generation coming up i can
say this because i now i'm
blessed to have a bioengineering student
they think about problems so differently
than biologists do we we realized the
other day we both came up with a set of
ideas around a certain project and we
realized that
her version of it was the exact opposite
of mine you know and hers was far
far more rational it's just an
engineering perspective like why would
we
do that last we should do that first i
think that the next generation is really
interested in solving practical problems
so a lot like computer science and
engineering was in the late 90s it was
like
you can go do a phd in computer science
and engineering maybe
or you go work for a company and
actually build stuff that's useful
i think neuroscientists and people
interested in neuroscience are starting
to think
how can i build stuff that's useful and
this statement is supported by the fact
that many
people in my business leave their
academic labs
fortunately not all of them but they
leave their academic labs and they go
work for companies
like neural link like neural links
you